I rebuilt our military including our
nuclear capability and the creation of
space force first time in 79 years
which is a big deal too
they surrendered our strength and turned
Afghanistan into the greatest
humiliation our country has ever had and
now we have a war between Russia and
Ukraine with potentially hundreds of
thousands of people dying that would
never have happened if I were president
would never it was not even thinkable
number one the energy cost the price per
barrel was at forty dollars he can't
have a war he can't afford it at a
hundred dollars he can afford it the
election was rigged and stolen and now
our country is being destroyed I ran
twice I won twice and did much better
the second time than I did the first
getting Millions more votes in 2020 that
I got in 2016 and likewise getting more
votes than any sitting president in the
history of our country by far and now in
order to make our country successful and
safe and glorious
I will very very very probably do it
again okay
[Applause]